Mike, you're reporting that Michael Jordan...
...is the first US professional athlete to become a billionaire.
That's right.
How did he get there?
Well, the last several months Kurt, Jordan, who is the majority owner of the Hornets...
...and has been since 2010 when he bought out Robert Johnson for 175 million dollars,...
...has been slowly increasing his ownership stake in the Hornets from 80% to 89.5%.
I've confirmed this from two sources familiar with the Hornets' financial documents.
People say the Hornets are worth between 600 million and 625 million.
We go with that lower conservative number,...
...that leaves Jordan's equity stake after subtracting debt...
...and cash he used to increase his stake worth 416 million.
When I take that net to his outside Hornet net worth which you calculate,...
...we get a total net worth of a billion dollars for Jordan.